♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HERE'S AN INTERESTING STORY, IF
THE NEW YORKER WERE STILL A REAL
MAGAZINE THEY MIGHT WRITE IT UP
BUT OF COURSE THEY WANT.
HERE IT IS, LAST SUMMER DEEP IN
THE OF THE TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENT IN WASHINGTON, SOME
NAMELESS ANALYST CAME ABOUT
HIGHLY PUZZLING TREND ON TRAFFIC
DEATHS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT IN THE YEAR
2020 THE NUMBER OF AMERICAN
MOTORISTS WHO DIED ON THE ROAD
SPIKED DRAMATICALLY.
TRAFFIC DEATHS ROSE BY MORE THAN
10% IN A SINGLE YEAR.
IN ANY YEAR THAT WOULD BE ODD
AND DISTRESSING, BUT COMING AS
IT DID IN 2020 IT WAS FLAT OUT
BIZARRE BECAUSE YOU WILL
REMEMBER IN 2020 THERE WAS A
PANDEMIC, MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
STAYED HOME THAT YEAR.
THEY DID NOT DRIVE TO WORK, MANY
DID NOT DRIVE IT ALL APPEARED IN
2020 ROADS WERE LESS CROWDED
THAN THEY HAD BEEN IN DECADES IN
THIS COUNTRY, SO OF COURSE YOU
WOULD EXPECT FAR FEWER TRAFFIC
DEATHS.
LESS TRAFFIC, FEWER PEOPLE DYING
IN TRAFFIC AND YES, THEY WERE
MORE TRAFFIC DEATHS.
I THINK THAT'S WEIRD?
WEIRDER.
IF YOU LOOK DEEP INTO THE
NUMBERS YOU WILL SEE THAT NOT
ONLY WERE MORE AMERICANS DYING
IN CARS AND 2020, A STAGGERING
NUMBER OF THOSE WHO DIED WERE
BLACK.
TRAFFIC DEATHS AMONG
AFRICAN AMERICANS ROSE NEARLY
25% IN A SINGLE YEAR.
THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED.
IN A NORMAL PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATION THAT QUESTION,
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING WOULD BE
THE SUBJECT OF URGENT ACADEMIC
STANDING.
PEOPLE ARE DYING, LET'S FIGURE
OUT WHY.
BUT IN THIS ADMINISTRATION IT
WAS NOT THE SUBJECT OF STUDY.
WHY QUESTION WORK BECAUSE
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS NOW THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION.
HE ONCE WORKED AT McKENZIE SO
HE ALREADY KNEW THE CAUSE OF
THESE DEATHS AND IT WAS,
NEEDLESS TO SAY, RACISM.
RACISM DID IT BECAUSE AMERICA'S
ROADS ARE RACIST, THEY'RE
KILLING BLACK PEOPLE.
AS "THE WASHINGTON POST" PUT IT,
THE TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT
CONCLUDED THAT BLACK COMMUNITIES
TEND TO BE CRISSCROSSED BY MOSTE
DANGEROUS ROADS.
THAT MADE SENSE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND YOU
CAN SEE WHY.
CIVIL ENGINEERS, ROAD BUILDERS
BENT ON WOULD NEEDLESS TO SAY
BUT ALL THE DANGEROUS ROADS IN
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS, THAT'S WHO
THEY ARE AND THAT KIND OF THING
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME IN AMERICA.
THIS IS A RACIST COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN HAS TOLD US THAT
COUNTLESS TIMES.
BUT WHAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IS
THE TIMING HERE.
VERY FEW OF THESE RACIST ROADS
ARE NEW.
MOST HAVE BEEN THERE A LONG
TIME.
SO WHY DID SO MANY BLACK
MOTORISTS SUDDENLY START DYING
IN THE YEAR 2020?
PETE BUTTIGIEG HAD NO IDEA.
HE DIDN'T EVEN BOTHER TO GUESS,
BECAUSE HONESTLY, HE DIDN'T
REALLY CARE.
BUT WE DO CARE AND WE'VE GOT A
THEORY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS YOU
WILL NOTICE THAT TRAFFIC DEATHS
AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN THE
YEAR 2020 SURGED IN THE MONTH OF
JUNE.
FATALITIES AMONG BLACK DRIVERS
IN JUNE 2020 WERE FULLY 55%
HIGHER THAN THEY WERE IN JUNE OF
2019.
YOU NEVER SEE INCREASES LIKE
THAT.
WHAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED?
WELL, LET'S SEE.
IT WAS IN THE LAST WEEK OF MAY
OF 2020 THAT A CONVICTED FELON
CALLED GEORGE FLOYD DIED IN
POLICE CUSTODY IN MINNEAPOLIS
AND IF YOU RECALL AFTER THAT
EVERYTHING CHANGED.
WHAT CHANGED MOST OF ALL IS HOW
WE REGARD TO THE RULE OF LAW.
THE HIGHWAY SAFETY ASSOCIATION
PUT IT, FLOYD'S DEATH
ACCELERATED NATIONAL DISCUSSION
ABOUT EQUITY AND TRANSPORTATION.
IN THE DISCUSSION WOULD INCLUDE
"QUESTIONS ABOUT ENFORCEMENT."
THERE IT IS RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S THE ANSWER.
COPS ACROSS THE COUNTRY WERE
TOLD TO STOP ENFORCING TRAFFIC
LAWS AGAINST BLACK DRIVERS.
NO ONE WANTED TO BE ACCUSED OF
ARRESTING SOMEONE FOR THE CRIME
OF "DRIVING WHILE BLACK."
IN THE NAME OF EQUITY THE LAW NO
LONGER APPLY TO HUGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE.
RESULT?
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS DIED.
THIS IS A TREND, YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED, AND IT DOESN'T JUST
APPLY TO TRAFFIC AND IT DOESN'T
JUST CAUSE TRAFFIC DEATHS.
HERE'S A CHARGE THAT SHOWS THE
NUMBER OF BLACK AMERICANS
MURDERED EVERY YEAR FROM 2010 TO
2020.
LOOK CAREFULLY AND YOU NOTICED
TWO MAJOR SPIKES.
ONE SPIKE IN 2014 COME EXACTLY
THE MOMENT THE MEDIA DECIDED TO
LIE TO US ABOUT THE DEATH OF
MICHAEL BROWN AND FERGUSON WAS A
REPAIRED ACTIVIST USED THE FALSE
STORY TO DRIVE POLICE OUT OF
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS IN MANY
PARTS OF AMERICA.
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER.
FEWER COPS, LESS RACISM, RIGHT?
NO.
IN EFFECT A LOT OF PEOPLE GOT
KILLED AND MOST OF THEM WERE
BLACK.
THEN THERE IS THE SECOND SPIKE
IN THE LAST DECADE, THE BIGGEST
ONE YET.
AS WE SAID, IT CAME IN THE
SUMMER OF 2020 AND IT'S
CONTINUING TODAY.
SAME REASON, SAME EFFECT.
THERE AREN'T A LOT OF TRENDS IN
SOCIAL SCIENCE THAT CAN BE
EXPLAINED IN A SINGLE GRAPH BUT
THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
UNLESS LAW ENFORCEMENT MEANS
MORE CRIME, AND OVER TIME, IT
MEANS MORE DEAD CHILDREN, MORE
GRIEVING PARENTS.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE
CRIMINOLOGIST UNDERSTAND THIS IS
VERY OBVIOUS.
EVEN LORI LIGHTFOOT GETS IT.
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS IN OF THE
MAYOR OF CHICAGO.
THANKS TO HER EQUITY BASED
POLICIES THE CITY OF CHICAGO IS
FALLING APART, PEOPLE ARE DYING
IN HUGE NUMBERS.
SHOOTINGS IN CHICAGO JUMPED 60%
LAST YEAR.
LORI LIGHTFOOT KNOWS PURPOSELY
WHILE THIS IS HAPPENING.
SHE KNOWS WHY IT IS HAPPENING
BUT LORI LIGHTFOOT DOESN'T CARE.
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS SO
UNINTERESTED IN ALL OF THOSE
DEATHS THAT SHE WON'T EVEN
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT IT WHEN
ASKED.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE COMING FROM
TUESDAY THIS WEEK.
SPEAK EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A
PRESS CONFERENCE YOU SAY A
CRIME IS DOWN, THE ECONOMY IS
BOOMING --
>> WELL, THAT IS NOT TRUE BUT
GET YOUR QUESTION, SIR.
>> Reporter: ACROSS THE STREET
WE HAD A POLICE OFFICER ON DUTY
THE VICTIM OF A HIT-AND-RUN.
WE HAVE MICHIGAN AVENUE, THE
MAGNIFICENT MILE IS NOW REFERRED
TO AS THE MILE OF FEAR.
THE WATER TOWER PLACE HAS THROWN
THE KEYS BACK TO THE LENDER.
THEY SAY THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
IN CHICAGO ANYMORE.
REAL CHICAGOANS ARE ASKING ME,
HOW COULD YOU POSSIBLY EVEN
CONSIDER RUNNING FOR REELECTION
AS MAYOR OF THE CITY OF CHICAGO
AFTER ALL THE HARM YOU'VE
CAUSED?
>> I DISAGREE WITH YOU
FUNDAMENTALLY, AND I DON'T THINK
I NEED TO ADDRESS AND DIGNIFY
YOUR COMMENTS ONCE I SECOND
FURTHER.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> Tucker: NEXT QUESTION.
LORI LIGHTFOOT WON'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION PRECISELY BECAUSE SHE
KNOWS THE ANSWER.
IN THE NAME OF EQUITY, OFFICIALS
IN CHICAGO HAVE STOPPED
ENFORCING THE LAW.
NOT SOME ESOTERIC TAX LAW THAT
NO ONE UNDERSTANDS, THE BASIC
LAWS, LIKE YOU CAN'T HURT OTHER
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE RELEASING CRIMINALS
THAT GO ON TO MURDER MORE
CITIZENS.
THIS IS THE TRIUMPH OF IDEOLOGY.
THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE THAT COMES
FROM FOX 'CHICAGO STATION.
SPEAK OF THE DETAILS ON THE
OFFENDER'S PRIOR HISTORY DOES
CALL INTO QUESTION HOW HE WAS
RELEASED.
THIS DOCUMENT SAYS IN JUNE OF
2021, 16-YEAR-OLD ANTHONY BROWN
LED POLICE ON A FOOT CHASE.
THAT IS WHEN THEY RECOVERED A
LOADED .22 CALIBER GLOCK HANDGUN
WITH AN EXTENDED MAGAZINE.
FIVE DAYS LATER HE WAS RELEASED
ON ELECTRONIC MONITORING.
14 DAYS LATER THE BRACELET CAME
OFF AND HE WAS PUT ON A CURFEW.
SIX MONTHS LATER, THEY SAY HE
WAS INVOLVED IN A CARJACKING.
THIS TIME POLICE RECOVERED A
LOADED GLOCK 9-MILLIMETER
HANDGUN WITH AROUND IN THE
CHAMBER.
THAT'S WHEN HE WAS PUT BACK ON
MONITORING.
IN THE CASE OF TUESDAY'S
SHOOTING OF THE 16-YEAR-OLD IS
CHARGED WITH FIRST-DEGREE MURDER
AND CARJACKING.
HE CARJACKED A LIFT DRIVER
EARLIER IN THE DAY AND TOOK OFF
IN THE SAME INFINITY AFTER AN
ALLEGED SHOOTING OF A TEEN HE
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW.
>> Tucker: STORIES LIKE THIS
CONSTANTLY IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO, THEY ARE ALWAYS THE
SAME BUT DETAILS OF THIS WILL
TELL YOU EVERYTHING.
CRIMINAL RUNS FROM THE POLICE
CARRYING AN ILLEGAL GUN.
IN THE SAME POLITICIANS WHO
NEVER STOP LECTURING YOU ON GUN
CONTROL, IT'S IMMORAL TO DEFEND
YOURSELF, THEY SCREAM AT YOU,
THOSE SAME PEOPLE LET THIS GUY
WHO USED HIS GUN TO COMMIT A
CRIME LET OUT OF JAIL
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE EQUITY.
THEN HE GETS RID OF HIS ANKLE
MONITOR AND COMMITS A
CARJACKING.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
LORI LIGHTFOOT'S FRIENDS
RELEASED HIM ONCE AGAIN BECAUSE
INCARCERATION IS BAD.
SO WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE DRIVES OFF TO SHOOT AND KILL
A 15-YEAR-OLD.
BECAUSE WHY WOULDN'T HE?
THERE'S NO PENALTY.
TRAGEDIES LIKE THIS HAPPEN
OCCASIONALLY HE WOULD CALL
THEM ACCIDENTS.
YOU WOULD FEEL SAD BUT YOU
WOULDN'T BE BOTHERED.
THESE ARE NOT ACCIDENTS, THESE
ARE HAPPENING EVERY DAY IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO.
43% OF ALL CRIMINALS CONVICTED
COMMIT NEW CRIMES WITHIN THREE
YEARS OF BEING RELEASED.
SOME ARE RELEASED VERY.
THAT IS A HIGH NUMBER COMPARED
TO OTHER STATES.
IN SANER PLACES LIKE TEXAS,
WEST VIRGINIA, THE RECIDIVISM
RATE AFTER THREE YEARS IS ABOUT
HALF OF THAT.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
POLITICS.
IT'S NOT A PARTISAN TALKING
POINTS, IT'S TRUE.
FOR THE LAST PLACES, THE MOST
LIBERAL STATE IN THE COUNTRY,
CALIFORNIA, HAS REPORTED A
RECIDIVISM RATE OF NEARLY 50%.
KEEP IN MIND THE IRONY HERE.
THEY TELL YOU THAT WE SHOULDN'T
INCARCERATE PEOPLE BECAUSE
INCARCERATION DOESN'T WORK AND
IF YOU WANT TO REHABILITATE YOU
HAVE TO LET THEM OUT.
THEY ARE NOT REHABILITATED.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE REOFFENDING
ALMOST 50% IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, SO INCARCERATION HAS
TWO PURPOSES.
ONE IS TO IMPROVE THE PRISONERS
SO HE WON'T REOFFEND, BUT THE
MAIN PURPOSE IS TO PROTECT THE
REST OF US WHO AREN'T COMMITTING
CRIMES WHO HAVE KIDS AND JUST
WANT TO LIVE A NORMAL LIFE.
THEY FORGOT ABOUT THAT PART.
EVERYTHING CALIFORNIA
POLITICIANS RELEASED REALLY
DANGEROUS CRIMINALS BACK INTO
THE PUBLIC SPHERE, AND THIS IS
WHY YOU ARE NOW TAKING A VERY
BIG RISK IF YOU DARE TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES.
HE COULD BE SHOT OR
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
WE ARE NOT GUESSING, WE HAVE THE
TAPE.
HERE IS SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE
FROM L.A. PLUS RISK TRANSIT
SYSTEM THAT INCLUDES PICTURES OF
A WOMAN BEING RAPED IN PUBLIC AS
SHE IS SITTING DOWN.
IT HAPPENS IN PUBLIC AND IT
HAPPENS A LOT.
WE WENT TO L.A. FOR THE PREMIERE
OF SEASON TWO OF OUR DOCUMENTARY
SERIES.
WE WENT THERE BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO UNDERSTAND HOW ONE MAN,
PROSECUTOR BACKED BY
GEORGE SOROS, COULD HAVE DONE SO
MUCH IN SUCH LITTLE TIME TO
DESTROY THE CITY.
WE TALKED OF THE FAMILY OF A
MURDER VICTIM CALLED FATIMA
JOHNSON.
>> FATIMA JOHNSON, A MOTHER OF
SIX, WAS FOUND BRUTALLY MURDERED
IN HER APARTMENT.
>> SHE WAS VIOLENTLY MURDERED,
BEATEN TO DEATH, HOG-TIED AND
GAGGED.
>> Tucker: THE SUSPECT IS A
CAREER CRIMINAL CALLED DARRELL
COLLINS.
HE SERVED DECADES IN PRISON FOR
TWO MURDERS AS WELL AS A STRING
OF ARMED ROBBERIES.
>> HE HAD QUITE AN EXTENSIVE
CRIMINAL HISTORIES, A SERIES OF
ARMED ROBBERIES.
HE KILLED TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE
ON SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
HE WAS UNDER 25 WHEN HE
COMMITTED THE MURDERS.
HE WAS ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE AND
PAROLE DECIDED IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
REHABILITATED YOURSELF AND WE
WILL RELEASE YOU.
IT WAS A HUGE MISTAKE.
>> HE CAME IN AND TOLD MY MOM HE
WAS GOING TO MARRY HER, AND YOU
KNOW, HE WOULD BE OUR STEPDAD,
PRINCE CHARMING BOL [BLEEP].
>> Tucker: DESPITE PREVIOUS
CONVICTIONS FOR MURDER AND
DESPITE THE FACT THAT FATIMA
JOHNSON WAS BOUND AND
HORRIFYINGLY TORTURED BEFORE SHE
WAS KILLED, GEORGE GASCON IS
REFUSING TO ADD ANY ENHANCEMENTS
TO THIS CASE.
GEORGE GASCON IS NOT THE ONLY
CORRUPT PROSECUTORS DOING THIS.
GEORGE SOROS HAS PAID PEOPLE
JUST LIKE GEORGE GASCON, AND
CHICAGO, ALVIN BRAGG NOW IN
MANHATTAN, OTHERS.
IN EVERY CASE, MANY AMERICANS,
THOUSANDS OVERALL HAVE DIED AS A
RESULT.
WHO IS BENEFITING FROM THIS
SLAUGHTER AND HOW EXACTLY ARE
THEY BENEFITING CUSTOMER THAT IS
A FAIR QUESTION YOU HAVE TO
WONDER.
WE KNOW VOTERS DON'T WANT IT.
AMERICA'S WANT THE LAWS THEY
BOUGHT A FOUR TO BE ENFORCED AND
THAT IS TRUE OF BLACK VOTERS
BECAUSE WHY WOULDN'T A BEQUEST
MARK SORRY LIBERALS, --
A NEW PUPIL PROVES THIS.
IT ASKED WHAT BLACK ADULTS CARED
ABOUT MOST.
IT WASN'T RACISM OR DIVERSITY
AND EQUITY, THAT WAS MADE ABOUT
THE BOTTOM.
WHAT THEY CARED ABOUT MOST WAS
VIOLENCE AND CRIME GET THAT IS
WHAT THEY CARED ABOUT.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY CARE ABOUT.
PETE BUTTIGIEG, THOUSANDS OF
BLACK PEOPLE ARE DYING OF
GUNSHOT WOUNDS.
PEOPLE ARE SICK OF THIS.
HE IS FACING A RECALL WHICH
COULD SUCCEED.
AMONG OTHER THINGS ENCOURAGED
OPEN AIR NARCOTICS MARKETS
THROUGHOUT SAN FRANCISCO AND AS
A RESULT, YOU GUESSED IT, MORE
THAN TWICE AS MANY PEOPLE HAVE
DIED OF DRUG ODs IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAN COVID.
WHO COULD SUPPORT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
IT'S PRETTY OUT OF TOUCH.
SINGER JOHN LEGEND DOES.
I ENDORSE CHESS WHEN HE RAN FOR
REELECTION AND I SUPPORT HIM
NOW.
OF COURSE YOU DO, JOHN LEGEND.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT
THE MUSCLE ALSO.
THEY RATED AN APARTMENT WHERE
THEY FOUND A DOG CALLED PABLO.
THE DOG HAD BEEN STOLEN AT
GUNPOINT BY THIEVES WHO ALSO
TOOK DRUGS AND MONEY, AT
GUNPOINT.
THE POLICE ARRESTED FOUR MEN IN
THE APARTMENT.
IF HE WAS LATER JOE BIDEN'S
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED IT
WAS REFUSING TO CHARGE.
SPEAK OF THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE HAS DECIDED NOT TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH WHAT THEY WERE
CHARGED WITH AND CONFIRMS THAT E
ARRESTED HAVE BEEN RELEASED.
I CAN TELL YOU, THE SEVEN PEOPLE
ARRESTED YESTERDAY WERE CHARGED
WITH RECEIVING STOLEN PROPERTY.
PABLO WAS ONE OF TWO DOGS STOLEN
DURING A WEDNESDAY VIOLENT CRIME
SPREE THAT POLICE SAY IT LASTED
NEARLY AN HOUR.
THERE WERE FOUR INCIDENTS
REPORTED IN THAT TIME FRAME
INCLUDING A DOUBLE SHOOTING IN
NORTHEAST D.C. ALONG WITH THE
ARMED ROBBERIES OF TWO DOG
OWNERS.
PLEASE TELL US THAT WHEN THEY
WERE COVERED IN THE NORTHEAST
D.C. APARTMENT THAT THEY ALSO
APPREHENDED SOME ITEMS HERE
INCLUDING DRUGS, A PISTOL, AND
AR-15 STYLE RIFLE, AND
AMMUNITION.
>> Tucker: WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU ALLOW PEOPLE TO COMMIT
VIOLENCE?
THE ONE THING THIS STATE CAN
NEVER DO, THEY HAVE A MONOPOLY
ON VIOLENCE.
IN A DEMOCRACY WE DECIDE WENT
VIOLENCE IS APPROPRIATE BUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU ALLOW
ANTISOCIAL ELEMENTS, COMMIT ALL
THE VIOLENCE YOU WANT, YOU GET A
LOT OF VIOLENCE.
INTERCITY YOUR
CITIES RESEMBLE.
PEOPLE ARE EXECUTED IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
THAT HAPPENED IN ATLANTA.
>> SECURITY GUARD GETTING OUT OF
HIS VEHICLE ON MONDAY NEAR
CLEVELAND AVENUE IN SOUTHWEST
ATLANTA.
LITTLE DOES FRASER KNOW HE'S
ABOUT TO BE MURDERED.
NOW WATCH AS THE SUSPECTED
GUNMAN WALKS TOWARDS HIM WITH A
PISTOL IN HIS RIGHT HAND.
ANOTHER MAN SITTING THERE WILL
WATCH THE WHOLE THING HAPPEN.
PLEASE DON'T SHOW THE ACTUAL
SHOOTING, JUST THE AFTERMATH.
FRAZIER LAYING THERE ON THE
GROUND DEAD, HIS BLOODIED BODY
HAS BEEN BLURRED.
THE ALLEGED GUNMAN GOES THROUGH
HIS BELONGINGS BEFORE CASUALLY
WALKING AWAY FROM THE SCENE.
REMARKABLY, THE WITNESS WHO WAS
SITTING AT THE CORNER, GETS UP
AND WALKS BY FRAZIER'S LIFELESS
BODY, JUST SHAKING HIS HEAD IN
APPARENT DISBELIEF.
THEN TWO OTHER MEN APPROACHED
THE VICTIM AND ALSO APPEAR TO
SEARCH HIM.
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK, WE HAVE
ZOOMED IN ON THE VIDEO AS THEY
THEN WALK AWAY WITH WHAT APPEARS
TO BE THE DECEASED VICTIM'S
WALLET.
>> Tucker: THERE WAS SOMETHING
REALLY WRONG WITH EVERYONE IN
THE VIDEO EXCEPT THE DEAD MAN.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE
REST OF US FOR PUTTING UP WITH
THIS AND NOT FIGURING OUT
EXACTLY WHY IT IS HAPPENING.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED
THAN RACISM.
SOMETHING REALLY DARK IS GOING
ON HERE BUT WE CAN SAY THESE
SORTS OF THINGS HAPPEN A LOT
MORE THAN THEY OTHERWISE WOULD
WHEN YOU DECIDE THAT LAWS SHOULD
BE APPLIED ON THE BASIS OF SKIN
COLOR.
WHEN YOU DECIDE THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE DIE, THEY BLEED OUT IN
GUTTERS ON CITY STREETS WHILE
THE REST OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD
HIDES INDOORS IN TERROR.
AS IT HAPPENS MOST OF THE DEBT
COME FROM THE VERY GROUP OUR
LEADERS SAY THEY A